hello and welcome so I'm going to talk
about residual Dynamic mode
decomposition there are two references
for this talk which I've listed down
here if you're interested do have a read
and you can always email me if you have
further questions or comments okay so
what this talk should really be called
is a very easy way to get error bounds
for your DMD computations
so we're interested in the following
problem we have some discrete time
dynamical system with a state X inside
some State space Omega and this is
governed by an unknown function f okay
so the state at time n plus 1 is given
by F of the state at time n
and our goal is to learn properties of
this dynamical system by observing
snapshot data or trajectory data in the
form X always in blue and Y always in
green where Y is equal to f of x so this
could come from a single long trajectory
or multiple shorter bursts the data
could also arise from experiments okay
so you literally measure a system or a
numerical simulation and you want to use
it for things like forecasting control
design or simply understand the
dynamical system at hand okay so this is
the goal of this talk how are we going
to achieve this goal well we're going to
look at something called
kubman operators and cumin operators act
on functions on the state space system G
from the state space Omega to the
complex numbers
and you define the kubern operator
through this composition formula here
okay so kg is another function evaluated
at time n is G evaluated at time n Plus
1.
now this composition formula allows you
to show that the kubern operator is a
linear operator so here's the picture
you've gone from a non-linear
representation in state space to a
linear representation in function space
and the cumin operator allows you to map
between the two okay so this looks
absolutely fantastic we're going from
something possibly horribly non-linear
to something linear but there is a catch
the cumin operator acts on an infinite
dimensional function space so you've
gone from something on the one hand that
was finite dimensional but non-linear to
something that's infinite dimensional
and linear
okay so although you're in infinite
Dimensions the linearity still allows
you to say lots of useful things about
the dynamical system if you could
somehow capture this equipment operator
for example under suitable conditions
you can expand an observable G in terms
of eigenfunctions whose coefficients are
known as Cuban modes and also certain
things that I've labeled The Continuous
Spectrum which is an integral over
generalized or non-normalizable
eigenfunctions
here's an analog if we put white light
through a prism we split it up into its
different wavelengths in a very similar
fashion this decomposition split sub g
into a bunch
of simpler parts and we know how these
simpler Parts behave under the Dynamics
in a very similar fashion if you look at
the solar radiation okay and look at the
intensity for different wavelengths you
can get a picture of the chemical
composition of the sun okay so by
studying this decomposition we can
answer questions about the original
dynamical system
for example if you want to evaluate G in
a future time step the nth time step
this is the same thing as applying the
cumin operator n times okay almost by
definition of this composition formula
well we know how the equipment operator
acts in eigenfunctions so you get this
power of the eigenvalue here in a very
similar fashion for the continuous
Spectrum you get this phorotype integral
more generally the Kumon mode
decomposition encodes all sorts of
information about the dynamical system
for example it's geometric features in
varying measures long and short time
Behavior coherent structures for example
these coefficients here our recruitment
modes are Quasi periodicity
Etc
right so our goal now becomes the
data-driven approximation of the
spectral properties of the Koopman
operator so we've got an infinite
dimensional operator and we want to
approximate its spectral properties from
a finite amount of snapshot data
so at some point
we're going to have to take a truncation
to a finite Matrix okay you might do
that using something like Dynamic mode
decomposition and I'll show you in a
couple of slides how that ties in with
this framework okay so you've got the
kubernet operator and you truncate
if you do that in compute eigenvalues
you can run into all sorts of issues
three in particular you can suffer from
too much so there can be eigenvalues of
that finite Matrix that are spurious
that have nothing to do with the true
infinite dimensional equipment operator
that's giving you misleading coherent
structures in your dynamical system when
you perform the analysis
you could also suffer from too little so
you can miss you can completely Miss
parts of the spectrum okay which means
you miss a potentially important
Dynamics
and then finally if you have an
algorithm or a numerical method you want
to ask the question or answer the
question is it right right verification
can I trust the output can I do a
computation which also comes with an
error bound or an error guarantee
okay so I'm going to show you how you
can use residual Dynamic mode
decomposition to tackle these three
issues in a very very simple manner
our starting point is extended Dynamic
mode decomposition
now this framework Works in a space of
square summable functions for us the key
point is that there's an inner product
structure this angled brackets here
and what you do is you take the snapshot
data up here x in blue Y in green and
you form an approximation of two types
of inner products
the first is the inner products between
the observables or the basis functions
themselves to do that you need this PSI
X Matrix in blue this is simply the
observables evaluated at The X part
of the snapshot data I also have some
weights
which wait how important each
observation or snapshot data is
the second type of inner product is when
you've got K acting on the left here on
one of the observables in the inner
product here you simply replace this PSI
X matrix by its corresponding PSI y
Matrix okay so those are the observables
evaluated at the Y points
once you've got these two inner products
or these two matrices
you can form your Matrix approximation
of the coupon operator with this formula
here now DMD will be a special case
of this form of this algorithm where the
observables so the functions PSI here
are linear
okay so it's all in a unified framework
right so we've got two types of matrices
we've got blue blue or PSI X PSI X we've
also got a blue green or PSI X PSI y
there's a third type of Matrix we can
consider which is PSI y PSI y or green
green if we're going by the color codes
this corresponds to having a coupon
operator acting on both observables both
functions in the inner product
so to summarize the edmd matrices you've
got two you've got G here
blue blue
a
blue green
for res DMD or residual Dynamic mode
decomposition you have this third Matrix
l
green green okay so why is this useful
suppose for example that I have a
candidate eigenpair Lambda G okay so G
is expanded in my observables as so
um one way of measuring the error how
close this eigen pair is to the true
spectrum is to look at this relative
squared residual so here I'm taking the
residual of kg minus Lambda G squared
and integrated over the state space
Omega
for example if G was an eigenfunction
with eigenvalue Lambda this numerator
would be identically zero more generally
this tells you how close to the Spectrum
you are and the beautiful thing is you
can approximate this error which is an
error in sort of the infinite
dimensional function space for the true
kubern operator using these three
matrices with this nonlinear Matrix
pencil that I've shown down here
okay so by looking at this additional
Matrix you've got access to error bounds
note that I can construct this Matrix
from the same data that I used for edmd
okay so I don't require any additional
data
let's look at an example so here I've
got a periodic Cascade of aerofoils so
the flow comes in here and then out
okay or if I rotate in and then out the
Reynolds number of the flow is
approximately 4 times 10 to the 5.
and the dimension of the dynamical
system that I'm considering is
approximately 300 000 which corresponds
to the number of points at which I
measure the pressure field
here are the kubernet modes computed
using Dynamic mode decomposition for
different
lambdas or spectral parameters
the arguments here by the way correspond
roughly to the frequencies that you'd
hear for this system the application
being noise reduction
Okay so we've got some interesting
coherent structures here what looks like
a turbine boundary layer and then an
acoustic Source in panel C
let's now look at the same Kuma modes
but with res DMD so now the physical
picture is very different okay you've
got strong acoustic vibrations in panel
a in panel B you've got a much larger
turbulent boundary layer and then over
in panel C you've got what looks like a
suppression of the acoustic Source due
to nonlinear effects now the reason the
physical picture looks different is I'm
using a kernel for the basis Choice here
or the choice of observables but
with wonky difference I get an error
bound
okay so when I compare DMD on the
previous slide with
res DMD
I can say which one is is physically
accurate because the res DMD comes with
guaranteed error bounds okay so I can
compute coupon modes with our bounds
that's fantastic
I can also do a lot more with this
residual so this is the formula for the
residual which remember involves these
three matrices which are constructed
from the snapshot data
for example I can avoid the problem of
too much okay to do that I simply
discard candid eigen pairs where the
residual is too large I can also avoid
too little to do that I search for local
minimizers of this residual finally
verification the algorithms come with
error bounce so if you're interested in
the theorems proving these results and
also the algorithms written out
explicitly then please consult our
papers
you can also use a resdmd to compute the
kuma mode decomposition with error
control and even verify your choice of
observables
right so here's an example of a verified
koopment mode decomposition so I have
a plasma cannon that blasts some air and
causes an initially supersonic shock
wave okay and I want to look at the
pressure field
so here I'm trying to predict the shape
of the pressure wave in blue
I train the Cooper matrices on a bunch
of experimental realizations and then I
test them I test the Cooper mode
decomposition on an unseen realization
and I'm going to consider two types of
compression the first I've called
modulus ordering these red dots here so
that's where I keep the 40 modes with
the largest energy content
the second in Black I've called residual
ordering and that's where I keep the 40
modes with the smallest residual so
there's two types of truncation going on
here there's an energy truncation the
modulus and then there's a residual
truncation the residual ordering the
hope is that the residual ordering
allows us to somehow figure out which of
those modes are really there and
correspond to the infinite dimensional
equipment operator and you can see
the residual ordering does a much better
job at predicting this non-linear wave
using the kuma mode decomposition
we can quantify this by looking at the
error here in terms of the number of
modes
and the punch line is that the residual
ordering leads to a much more efficient
compression of the information in your
nonlinear dynamical system or your
measurements
finally you can use resdmd to verify
your choice of observables so in this
experiment I have a jet and I have a
plate okay so I have a field of view
over here some turbulent flow with a
boundary down here
the Reynolds number is approximately six
times ten to the four the dimension of
the dynamical system is about 100 000
corresponding to both horizontal and
vertical velocity measured at
approximately 50 000 points okay so this
is experimental data
um so I'm going to compute the
eigenvalues
using residual DMD
both with a linear basis
okay so the residuals are shown as color
here and also with a kernel basis
okay again the residuals and what you
see is that particularly close to one
over here
the kernel basis does a much better job
at reducing spectral pollution and
having eigenvalues with a smaller
residual okay so using these types of
figures we were able to figure out which
a good which was a good choice of
observables to study the equipment
operator on okay so you can get a handle
as to whether your your space is Rich
enough to capture the Dynamics
so we were able to discover some
interesting Kuma modes both a long
lasting and transient mode and again
these come with explicit
error bounce using the residual
so to summarize edmd considers two types
of matrices okay this of course also
includes DMD as a special case you have
blue blue psyx PSI X
blue green psyx PSI y
all we do is consider a new Matrix l
PSI y PSI Y and this leads to residuals
which lead to error bounds once we've
got the residual we open up the
Machinery of infinite dimensional
spectral computations and this allows us
to do a whole bunch of things for
example we avoid too much we avoid
spurious eigenvalues we avoid too little
we converge to the whole of the spectrum
of the koopment operator
resdmd provides explicit error bounds
for cumin eigenfunctions eigenvios and
biodecompositions it verifies
computations right all of this stuff
comes with error control for example you
can use this to verify a learned
observable or a learned dictionary of
functions that you're looking at
resdmd finally is very easy to use with
any existing DMD type method you just
need to form this additional Matrix
a final comment
you can use resdmd to compute continuous
Spectra now if you're interested in this
please consult our paper we have
algorithms that do similar things for
the continuous Spectrum
okay so the code for SDM can be found
here you can also look at my website if
you're interested in further papers uh
presentations and code as well thank you
very much for your attention